that's not the plan
uh he's got a big show at the novo is it
Thursday night yeah with nudie uh of
course baby drills here welcome sir
how you doing man skirt
um
uh welcome how's La been treating you
did you go to BT awards no I got here
too late for Beach it was but I've been
treating me smooth everybody tapping
there yeah
um how long you been rapping like would
you would you like kind of start like
you know recording taking this [__] real
serious probably a year and a half ago
it's not very long ago yeah
so you started like actually recording
for the first time a year and a half ago
yeah about two years ago it's at the max
two years but probably in half though so
you got you got locked up and then your
joint went crazy while you were
incarcerated right yeah but it was going
crazy when I was up yeah but it went it
was crazy when I got locked up yeah what
was like uh I mean for you like because
that was a 32 Freestyle right yeah
which number song was that for you was
that like one of your first like records
that you laid down or prefer one little
one that popped me off yeah that's the
one that changed things for you yeah it
changed everything
you get out of jail things are different
but I had a song newly too though so
like that was that was back and forth
from 32 freestyle to that side
how did you do the uh link up that's
fine my family and my dog
like family family or like I'm saying
like how did y'all end up initially you
know Family Blood come back Us in close
I might not did you guys uh for you like
seeing like what him and 21 were doing
did that like motivate you to like
really start taking the rap [__] serious
because I mean not everybody's got those
opportunities with those relationships
you know
made me feel like it's possible from a
[__] that you know what I'm saying from
the head
they didn't know a [__] like they can
do it yeah it's like yo if I see
somebody from where I'm from doing it
it's very possible hey
what would you say influence wise like
your sound like how you rap what would
you say your biggest influences are
oh no I ain't all silence I just created
my own sound so a lot
I rip off emotion though so most dude be
like anger
would you grow up listening to how about
that
I ever [__] though
sandwich baby
Gucci
would you say because I I always talk
about this do you think
who's the like god of the Trap [__]
because it's Gucci tip or Jeezy I feel
like it's one of those three in terms of
just like
I'm gonna go up yeah the greatest a r in
hip-hop history I say yeah
that's so hard
did you uh for you uh because you kind
of how old are you if you don't mind me
asking 21. yeah so you're 21. so you
were like a kid like P Gucci like a
small child you know what I'm saying so
I really listened to the rappers no yeah
my errors the [__] that's popping
right now yeah that's what I'm saying
100 man
um somebody like uh coming up under
someone like nudity Nudy's obviously
somebody who I feel like doesn't get
enough flowers in terms of just his
influence his catalog is so crazy
um is there something that he has taught
you that you apply to your whether it's
music shared maybe a live show [__] how
you record anything like that yeah
[__] gonna call and stay down
all that everybody do stay there yeah
he's definitely
I feel like Nudy's definitely got his
fingerprints over a lot of hip-hop right
now though we got it we gotta you know
start to acknowledge you know what I'm
saying what about Savage
yeah
he's giving you any advice yeah just
right choices decisions and [__]
right